staying overseas and to Nepal we go now
where hundreds of Rescuers are still
searching for survivors after a plane
crash that killed at least 68 people
Searchers found the plane's voice and
data recorders this morning four people
still unaccounted for in the rubble
there after yesterday's crash and police
say hopes of finding anyone alive are
fading Elizabeth Palmer has more now on
Nepal's deadliest accident in more than
30 years
in the evening another body journeyed by
ambulance from the crash site to a
hospital where loved ones waited hours
earlier a phone camera had caught the
plane flying low then abruptly tilting
before it hit the ground
it nose dived into a Gorge near Pokhara
a town popular with both Himalayan
Trekkers and pilgrims onlookers rushed
to the crash site while Rescuers
including the Nepali military scoured
the wreckage for signs of life but there
were none this is Nepal's worst civil
aviation disaster in 30 years the yeti
Airlines twin-engine turboprop had begun
what air traffic control said was a
normal approach to the brand new Pokhara
airport when something went disastrously
wrong now an investigation will try to
determine what that was most of those on
board were Nepali but included
passengers from Australia Ireland France
India Russia and South Korea Nepal has a
deadly air safety history nearly 350
people have been killed in crashes since
2000 including the most lethal one in
1992 where all 167 people on board the
plane died for CBS mornings I'm
Elizabeth Palmer in Tokyo